We've just gone over the essential
things that you need
to be able to train a simple
linear classification model.
Now, it's your turn.
How well does this work?
Pretty well, as you will see
in your first assignment.
The first part of it will
have you download and
pre-process an image data set that you
will be reusing throughout the lectures,
and that you can use
yourself to experiment with.
The second part will have you go
through an exact re-implementation,
piece by piece,
of all the components of the logistic
classifier that we've discussed so far.
Make sure that you carefully step
through the code before coming back to
the videos.
Run it, break it, tinker with it.
We'll be building on top of it for
the rest of the lecture.
You'll also quickly see some of
the problems with the simple approach.
It can be very slow.
Even for
a simple model like this linear model on
a very small amount of training data.
Scaling this up is what
deep learning is all about.